[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wels
das heutige video haben sich einige
gewünscht ich heute eine kinder pinguin
torte die kinder pinguins haben die
küche noch nicht erreicht airlines grad
noch einkaufen der holte ich hoffe die
kinder pinguins kommen hier auch an
sie sind natürlich nicht alleine
einkaufen kinder pinguin kennt ihr
vielleicht aus dem hurrikan zur info das
video ist nicht produkt platziert es
wird nicht bezahlt denn ich mache das
produkt eigentlich wieder nach sozusagen
in form einer torte und zwar ist es aus
dem kühlregal hat zwei schoko biscuit
schichten in der mitte eine helle sahne
creme und da in der mitte noch eine
schokoladen schicht richtig schön
knackig und das ganze mache ich jetzt
als torte das heißt die basis ist zuerst
ein schokoladen bist wird da gibt's auch
schon grundrezept auf einem kanal bei
bizkit muss man einfach immer nur
beachten
zwei teile ein teil zuckeranteil mehr da
ist ein schoko biscuit ist ein bisschen
weniger mehl und dafür noch kakaopulver
also habe ich jetzt hier an zutaten fünf
zimmer war mayer 125 gramm zucker eine
prise salz etwas vanille extrakt jetzt
habe ich hier noch mehr und kakao und
zwar 90 gramm mehl und 35 gramm cacau
das war es schon
und im prinzip sind die grundzutaten ei
zucker mehl kakao und die habe ich immer
da und kann jeder zeiten indiskret zu
bereiten
gebt ihr die zimmer waren eier hier an
zucker und saß dann man den extrakt dazu
und jetzt rührt ihr die masse für
mindestens zehn minuten besser noch 15
mit dem handrührgerät vielleicht sogar
damit die eier zuckermasse richtig schön
weiß cremig wird den ofen auch schon mal
vorheizen auf 180 grad tortenring
bereitstellen und losriss
jetzt ist die masse perfekt lange genug
gerührt kann ich hier mail und cacau 78
gesagt nicht cacau
[Musik]
habt ihr mir bei gemacht wenn ich ein
stolzer cacau sage das jetzt auf jeden
fall sieben damit einfach keine
klümpchen von frau und vom mieter
bleiben jetzt ganz vorsichtig unterheben
am besten mit einem schneebesen von
außen nach innen aber wie gesagt da
könnt ihr euch die tipps auch gerne noch
mal im basis video anschauen zum biscuit
ich hoffe da wird jetzt dunkel genug hab
ich glaub schon dass funkel der im ofen
nochmal schöner der kinder bingo ist ja
auch richtung und dann direkt in den
tortenring film ich habe jetzt hier
übrigens den biscuit nicht auf 26
umgerechnet sondern da wird jetzt ein
bisschen flacher
denn wenn ich jetzt den normalen bizkit
nehmen da ist einfach schön hoch und
dann aber zu hoch für die torte finde
ich denn in dem original kinder pinguin
ist ja auch dass ein bisschen dünner und
daher soll jetzt auch die torte ebene
dementsprechend stünde werden
jetzt verteilen und dann sofort im
vorgeheizten ofen backen
[Musik]
der biss fehlt ist das gebacken die
pinguine sind jetzt ja auch angekommen
jetzt mache ich die creme ich zeig euch
das jetzt mit dem mini e mails creme
rheins schwere gang zum nachmachen aber
da steige ich dann auf seine umwelt für
diskussionsstoff milchschnitte oder
kinder von dem kind ab ingolstädter
gegen die klitschko-brüder würde ich
schon sagen mehr auf die schnitte aber
geschmacklich werde ich schon hinter
sich habe ich keine kinder bringen wo
immer gegessen chance ließ also die
creme ist er seine kompakte creme nicht
schon lockere sammelt rehm aber ich
glaube ich mache jetzt also
normalerweise würde ich jetzt eine
kompaktere mascarpone sahne creme machen
aber weil ich nicht will dass die torte
so schwerins mache ich eine quark sahne
creme und hier ist auch kein honig drin
also ähnlich wie bei nicht wie bei der
milch schnitte
hier sind andere viele dinge drin aber
keinen keinen honig deswegen machen wir
jetzt eine wachsame kräftig recht kurz
die zutaten oder dem was an den kuchen
habe ich wie gesagt schon dies geht aus
dem ofen genommen habe ihn schon raus
gelöst da steht jetzt im kühlschrank
dann würde ich ihnen gleich gut
schneiden kann und dann machen wir es
die creme und später noch die show
geschichte
ich schreibe so cremig für die gräben
nämlich 250 gramm quark 50 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt 400
gramm sahne und sein apa zu schlagen so
denkbar gebe ich jetzt hier in die
schüssel
ich versuche jetzt die torte nicht so
süß zu machen wie die kinder pinguin
schnitt haben sich dann ließen wir schon
hin zu fisch also da verändert sich
glaube ich auch der geschmack je älter
man wird als kind verträgt man das echt
noch ganz gut so die ganze süße den
ganzen zucker aber jetzt einen ganzen
regel dann würde ich glaube ich nicht
mehr schaffen das wäre einfach zu süß
jetzt hier verrühren also quark butter
zucker und vanille
dann die sahne dazugeben es gibt eine
flockige aus aber so ist halt so bei der
biosauna das erste zimmer ab
[Musik]
perfekt wie stelle ich jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank und werde mich schon mal um
die schokoladen schicht kümmern da bin
ich gerade echt noch seine finger hand
co da vinci erste hat noch genauer
überlegen denn kinder pinguin ist das
eine schoko schicht schön knackig in der
torte darf sie natürlich nicht so
knackig sein wer schon geschmack nicht
cool aber dann beim anschnitt geht halt
dann der knatsch und dann geht das stück
kaputt
deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich mit
kokosöl und zusammenarbeiten das ist
einfach die schokolade bisschen weicher
wird aber trotzdem noch knackig bleibt
und die optik eben schön wird
also die sahne kocht jetzt jetzt den
herausstellen die schokolade dazu geben
und einfach verrühren bis sich alles gut
verbunden hat da es keine schneebesen
haben nämlich ein löffel ist jetzt auch
die frau des typs die restwärme die
regelt das von alleine da hinten holen
sich die jungs und mädels kuchen
erwartet doch schon geboren hat marcel
ich kenn dich doch marcel komm ich geb
dir schokokuchen bitteschön das
beantwortet doch die frage wer immer
alle videos alle videos ist alle alle
kuchen ist nicht nur die obst fliegen
okay es ist echt eklig egal sondern auch
das team später nichts mehr übrig lassen
so während die schokolade jetzt noch
schmilzt kann ich schon mal den biss mit
den habe ich ja schon raus gelöst da war
auch schon im kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich ihnen hier einmal stürzen
und von der folie zu lösen
wie ist das schön jetzt halbieren
[Musik]
ok jetzt nehme ich den unteren boden weg
den auf eine tortenplatte auch mit dre
platte also das ist jetzt nicht der
boden sondern der decke wie man sieht
den boden
nämlich dann für oben drauf ist aber
eigentlich egal weil beide seiten
wirklich schöne äpfel tropfen regen
drumherum
die creme die wiege ich jetzt ab denn
ich möchte dass die unterschicht und die
obere wirklich identisch sind
ich habe ungefähr etwas mehr als 700
gramm creme und ich möchte da noch was
für obendrauf
also nehme ich vielleicht 300 ich guck
mal jetzt wenig reich machen einfach
nochmal eine krems 350
[Musik]
jetzt wirklich versuchen ganz glatt zu
streichen
und jetzt friere ich die torte kurz ein
damit diese schicht einfach schön fest
wird die schokolade ist also noch ein
bisschen warm und dann kommt die show
geschäft haben
die sahne wird mir nicht reich sind
deswegen habe ich nochmal 100 kam dazu
gegeben
also ich ändert haben das rezept auf 500
gramm sahne und dann passt die torte
sind gefrustet also schön kalt auf der
oberfläche
jetzt nehme ich die schokolade die kommt
hier drauf da ist jetzt wirklich die
kunst die schönen glatt zu verstreichen
und gleichmäßig es geht halt echt am
besten mit drehtellern und am besten
nicht ganz bis zum rand das war so eine
so einen kleinen rand außen übrig so
frei
mit böse weniger sein dürfen vergesst
den rand vergesst was ich gesagt wir
machen es bis zum rand und jetzt kommt
die torte nochmal ins gefrierfach damit
die schoko schicht festwirt sei jetzt
wie so eine art garage also schon ein
bisschen weicher die schokolade nicht so
knapp fest wie eben die zarter
schokolade
das war das eben war es egal jetzt
kommen die noch mal ins gefrierfach wird
schön fest und dann kommt dieser nach
oben drauf also es geht die torte echt
recht schnell man muss einfach nur diese
kühl zeit beachten
im gefrierfach geht schneller im
kühlschrank dauert bisschen länger auf
den typ canadair bereits fest geworden
die schokolade vielleicht noch 20 gramm
sahne mehr machen müssen egal ihr
probiert so ich wollte den knapp also
kriege ich einen knapp die torte ich hab
hier bei mir schon alles alles vorbei da
kann man nichts mehr retten
nichts mehr zu retten ja schon ein
bisschen also zweite schicht und die
jetzt auch schön glatt streichen
[Musik]
ich hatte keine creme mehr übrig für die
deko also muss ich noch creme machen
und jetzt kommt der best wird drauf ich
drücke ihm jetzt ganz vorsichtig glatt
mit der bürger pressen
so das war's jetzt erstmal jetzt darf
die torte nochmal in die kühlung und ich
kann schon mal die schokolade
vorbereiten für den überzug und das
war's dann also das ist dann die torte
und ich denke die torten immer gerne ab
mit einem tropfen retter damit sei
einfach nicht austrocknen vor allem der
bizkit an der oberfläche eben nicht
austrocknet ich glaube ich stelle
gefrierschrank
ich habe jetzt hier mal zartbitter
kuvertüre für die deko außen denn ich
werde die komplette top damit gut
herüber ziehen wie ein kinderbuch auch
überzogen ist
die kuvertüre die teile ich jetzt zwei
drittel davon erwärme ich jetzt nämlich
direkt über dem wasserbad und das
restliche drittel nämlich zum
herunterkühlen
und ich nehme noch etwas kokosöl dazu
bei uns ist gerade echt war hier in der
küche deswegen ist das kokosöl auch ganz
flüssig normalerweise ist es bei
raumtemperatur er fest aber bei uns ist
raumtemperatur grad 26 28 grad bestimmen
so richtig 29 richtig warm
hier lässt sich das wasser kurz kochen
und stellt dann den herd aber aus so
könnte nämlich auch sichergehen dass
kein wasser in die schokolade kommt dass
sie nicht zu heiß wird
los los los los
[Musik]
wenn die schokolade dann geschmolzen ist
nehmt ihr sie direkt vom herd herunter
und mit dem restlichen drittel werde ich
sie jetzt herunterkühlen
so hat die kuvertüre gleich die perfekte
weitere verarbeitung temperatur hat
einen schönen glanz
deswegen macht man das die impf methode
sich eben jetzt sozusagen mit der besten
schokolade die flüssige schokolade und
dann wird sie genauso wie ich sie haben
möchte jetzt einfach schön verrühren bis
auch diese schokolade jetzt geschmolzen
ist
hier gebe ich jetzt auch das kokosöl
dazu damit die kuvertüre beim anschnitt
einfach nicht so fest ist ich habe auch
die sahnetorte konnte also das muss
schon ein bisschen geschmeidiger sein
und sie bekommen können glanz dadurch
jetzt habe ich sie verschüttet jetzt
habe ich rasch als man könnte jetzt auch
noch sahne dazugeben dann wird es wie so
eine art garage hat eine etwas festere
textur ich probiere es jetzt einfach so
denn ich möchte dass dickler so glänzt
jetzt habe ich hier so ein abtropfen mit
einem pizza blech darunter ok und nicht
mittig egal jetzt den tortenring lösen
[Musik]
hier noch mal glatt streichen und jetzt
probiere es einfach ich hoffe dass die
kuvertüre am rand hält wenn nicht kommt
halt noch nicht drauf und lass' auf los
geht's los
no risk no fun
[Musik]
und die kuvertüre die zieht jetzt auch
ziemlich schnell an die torte kommt in
den kühlschrank ich setze jetzt hier
auch gleich runter ich warte noch ein
bisschen bis ein bisschen ab tropft und
die schokolade die jetzt runter getropft
ist die können wir natürlich weiter
verwenden ihr könnt rockets draus machen
ihr könnt konflikts dazugeben und so
kleine schoko christie's machen also auf
jeden fall nicht wegschmeißen
aber man muss natürlich immer ein
bisschen mehr schmerzen als man braucht
damit es eben auch schon drüber fließen
kann also packe ich die torte jetzt mit
einem anderen gefäß darunter in den
kühlschrank und dann fühle ich die
sachen die ich noch steif geschlagen
habe in einen spritzbeutel und dann wird
fertig dekoriert
[Musik]
leider bekam die torte doch einen
grauschleier aber was soll's wir haben
einfach temperatur probleme in unserer
küche egal ist so ok ich mal kurz die
sahne keinen groschen ja entschuldigung
jungs ganz ehrlich ich habe doch erklärt
wir waren keine ein grauschleier
gekommen indem man diese impf methode
machst dieser zwei drittel ein drittel
und dann noch quartiere oder noch ach ja
und jetzt ist doch falsch gelaufen das
war halt doch noch nicht die richtige
temperatur
ich habe aber auch muss ich zugeben die
zwei drittel eintritt nicht abgewogen
eigentlich bin ich da immer sehr genau
ich wuchs dann ab 200 gramm 100 gramm
ich habe es nicht gemacht jetzt habe ich
leider raus und es nervt mich nervt mich
richtig ich könnte euch nicht vorstellen
wie sehr mich das problem
ich lasse das jetzt auch so weil ich mir
so denke das passiert für euch
vielleicht aber wahrscheinlich nur
perfekte torten von euch haben wenig
stolz und da macht nämlich noch mehr
traurig dass es passiert ist egal
ich lasse es historisch und jetzt kommen
wir so seine topfahrer drauf wir machen
alles wieder okay da seht ihr geld
gleich wieder ganz schön
[Musik]
und ich meine wenn ihr die torte nach
macht ihr braucht ja die pingo jetzt
nicht unbedingt für die deko also könnt
ihr eure kinder pinguin otto machen und
wo aber so für die deko dann sieht man
gleich was es sein soll
ich war hier immer dann einmal drüber
und scharnebeck warum lacht ihr nachdem
ich aus ich habe meine finger probiert
das kind hat sorry ich bin auch nur ein
mensch hatte das gefühl ich habe tim
bendzko den song geschrieben
ich bin noch keine maschine
ich bin ein mensch aus fleisch und blut
und ich will bug bis zum letzten atemzug
ich bin ein mensch mit all meinen
fehlern mit dem grauschleier und der
saane bin keine maschine
schlee von zucker und mehl zucker butter
im zeugnis würde stehen sie hat sich
stets bemüht doch sie hat beiden
gepredigt und wasser getrunken oder geht
es aber strom
es hat gepredigt wie der grauschleier
nicht geht und hat ihn dann doch
hinbekommen aber so ist es nun einmal so
ist das leben
von sally 29 früher war sie einmal
lehrerin
heute dreht sie durch
deswegen liebe kinder ich bin noch nicht
fertig ich bin noch nicht fertig
[Gelächter]
ich weiß da wollte ich mich gerade
bremsen aber nein
deswegen lieben kinderlein was
anständiges weil dort keine influenza
ihr seht wo es endet am steuer
jetzt bin ich fertig ist
[Musik]
wir probieren jetzt die torte morath
start testen
ich habe es messer bisschen angewärmt so
und das ist eine kinder kinder ping
winter ja ich habe leider vergessen
ich habe die saison ging ich glaube das
mag auch jeder gegen risiken oder
gefahren
als kind ist man halt irgendwie süßer
und als erwachsener bisschen weg sagt
das ist man ihm das ist doch jetzt eine
tolle geburtstagsparty wo sich wünscht
oder mal zu mal party resource aber es
ist übersieht die torte so gemacht dass
du hast wirst du hast die pinguine nur
zu zu dem sektor aber die talker schmidt
genau wie kinder pinky ich denke nicht
genau also zum einen will ich es nicht
so süß haben
das wollte ich nicht weil das chanson
regel okay aber es sieht optisch genauso
mein ganz gleich geht nicht weil das ist
eine milch krämer und du kannst so jetzt
keine milch creme ohne pulver und so
weiter aber so sieht's aus
natürlich immer einmal mit messer so
drüber und dann aber ich muss sagen es
ist alles einfach was die jungs bisher
schon ja eigentlich eins zu eins an
gleicher sieht 11 gleich und so dass man
sich doch auch probieren
also
ich werde mir kinder bringen so jetzt
weiß wie das kinderbild schmeckt jetzt
gehe ich mal wieder schmecken
alle waren so heran sein wird strauss
gemacht schmeckt die kinder pinguin nur
nicht so süß und durch den quark ist ein
leichter aber auch recht gut sagen aber
mit der schokolade das ist echt nicht so
süß muss ehrlich sagen und durch den
biss wird richtig locker ist es entweder
ich habe das kind haben nicht nur ein
spaß
ich wollte erst mal so eine richtig
große münchen wir haben uns wir sollen
die höchste die ich so tragen muss nicht
hat so essen kann wunderbar recht gut
also probiert die torte gerne ausbauen
ich habe auch schon viele torten die
sachen gemacht wie die kennt weiß auch
diese bauen die torte die war richtig
gut mit kokos ich habe irgendwann mal
die angst dass du angezeigten im konzern
der schon mal angezeigt man sagen
kopiert hat vom konzern die vom hsv
vielleicht vielleicht weil ich mal eine
tribute oder gemacht habe ich meine
geschichten erzählen
ja sagt heute erzähle ich euch die
geschichte
ich glaube dass ich kenne mich ja mit
fußball 0 aus also muss ich ganz kurz
die geschichte die uns war das ding also
es ist eine unglaubliche geschichte des
unglaublich passiert die muss ich euch
heute erzählen okay also die frage was
glaubt ihr
von wem wurde sally angezeigt also es
ist gucken raten wie so oft coppenrath
diese kopieren ist der ferrero kinder
oder oetker oder ist es der hsv hsv sagt
uns das ist ja was sagt hasso ratet mal
wer hat mich angezeigt
das heißt wenn das haus noch etwas nicht
habe ich coppenrath und was auch nicht
habe ich das nicht die waren es auch
nicht
es war das war der hsv jetzt keine ganz
kurzer exkurs in die geschichte
ich habe vor einigen jahren vor fünf
sechs sieben jahren da war mein kanal
echt noch klein also wirklich klein da
hatte ich vielleicht 100.000 abonnieren
also wie ich wo ich sagte komm schon
reichweite aber ganz wenig dann habe ich
unseren bürgermeister timm walter heiler
den ich gerade herzlichst grüße lieber
walter wir müssen uns mal wieder sehen
habe ich dem walter heil eine
geburtstagstorte gemacht und der walter
heiler ist wahrscheinlich der einzige
mensch auf der welt der hsv fans
irgendwann auf jeden fall ja also gar
nicht nur ich wusste nicht was heißt
also hunde haben
da habe ich gedacht habe das wäre echt
100 hsv und sportverein egal ich wusste
ich hab dann gegoogelt hab' gefunden hsv
so logo trikot da habe ich im wald und
zum sechzigsten geburtstag das trikot
gebacken und ich hatte nicht mal eine
eigene küche da waren gerade im umzug ja
und meint das küchenstudio hat so spät
geliefert ich musste im küchenstudio die
torte backen dann habe ich die dem
walter übergeben er hat eine schöne
geburtstagsparty und dann bis war es an
vor ungefähr zwei monaten kam vom
rechtsanwalt im brief vom
rechtsanwaltsbüro dass die die recht
nicht vom hsv hamburger sport-verein und
da stand drin das sowie vom wir
eigentlich die rechten hätten den hsv
tore zu machen also sie hat aus holland
das logo die raute vom hsv nachgemacht
und ungerecht
dafür haben am sein ehe natürlich haben
sie nicht mehr meine torte gebacken war
ja nichts besonderes
eine kostenlose torte für den
bürgermeister genau muss informiert dass
wir ehrlich sind sogar schon wieder
vergessen gehabt
das heißt dann warum dann behauptet das
anwaltsbüro dass wir das du dir die
starke bezug über den hsv spielt
übrigens in der zweiten liga seit
tradierten oder sind es zwei jahre
diese drei jahren sind schon
ok auf jeden fall spielen jede zweite
liga und da stand dann lief als
begründung die sally würde die stahl die
strahlkraft des hsv benutzen um groß zu
werden
ich habe bisher nie was von denen
gehören liebe hass raum
es gab mal zeiten von von thomas von
heesen uwe seeler
die feier ist drauf und es war ein
richtig coole zeit beim hsv muss ich
ganz ehrlich sein aber das ist echt der
hammer ohne spaß jetzt holen wir dieses
video das fünf jahre alt ist sollen wir
jetzt dass die / das wissen löschen so
weidlich zedi hat natürlich eine hsv
koffer gepackt als ich es verstehen und
sich der bayern münchen meldet wobei es
ja auch furchtbar dortmund oder oder
oder oder was weiß ich in anderen
vereinen borussia mönchengladbach es
gibt tausende von dortmund toppen im
internet aber bitte macht niemals ein
hsv tor
ja hallo ist jeder marcell jansen
bastian ich habe gar keine zeit ich rufe
die spiele dann auf jeden fall 200 maßen
ganz okay ich keine anonymität so auf
jeden fall habe ich kannte marcell
jansen gerufen aber wie auch immer das
ist die krasse geschichte also wirklich
dass ein sportverein anruft und sich
beschwert wenn eine grundschullehrerin
aus waghäusel eine torte hsv trat anfang
genau das nächste mal wenn er als
hauptort backen dann müssen wir erstmal
wahrscheinlich geld an den hsv bezahlen
da gibt es in ordnung ist und arbeiten
denen einfach das video die werbekosten
alles des volt man eine ganz große
geschichte also said viele gründe
angezeigt zu werden von irgendwelchen
herstellern wenn sie irgendwas kopiert
haben sie jetzt zum beispiel aber dann
meldet sich damals war das ist ein ganz
krasse geschichte ich hab so lachen
müssen ja alle gedacht ganz waghäusel
nach eine ganz ganz wichtig ja aber ich
möchte doch das thema weiterhin ausgehen
der hsv ist wir wollen nicht die
wahrheit wir wohl nicht trocken halten
da hast du eine zweite glück bestraft
hat natürlich kam auf jeden fall ganzen
vielleicht kümmert ihr euch nicht und
grundschullehrerinnen aus waghäusel
sondern vielleicht du mal klar ich muss
auch ganz ehrlich sagen ich mache sagt
pauly nicht mal st pauli ich finde dann
polizei schätzt ja so ist ein weingut
auch baumann ist einfach ein toller
verein muss ich ehrlich sein aber
eigentlich wollten wir gar keinen fall
langweilig so was ganz ehrlich ich habe
eigentlich sommer zu schalke 04 erwartet
ehrlich ich hab's locken kleine
abschalten will die habe ich aber nicht
die mannschaft macht ja noch nie und der
walter wird auch der einzige sein der
sich seine tochter wünscht von daher
liebe wahlgang leider das nächste mal
wenn du eine geburtstagsparty von hsv
fans bekommen zu seinem sechzigsten
geburtstag wobei über nicht mehr 60 oder
65 bekommst du leider kein hsv tor von
uns wenn es rechtliche schwierigkeiten
das paktiert dann eine kinder pinguin
oder ärmlich oder gewesen
genau muss man diesen krebs ist okay
also bis zum tod bis zu kopieren von von
bugs sachen ja macht's gut macht's
besser und das projekt übrigens meine
torten kopieren ja das macht sie gerne
nach und postet sieger ich habe auch
nichts dagegen weil liebe grüße an alle
deutschen fans gehen raus cse wahnsinnig
bayern münchen meldet sich um niemand
irgendjemand irgendwo oder hass hausecke
gekrochen das ist nicht normal oder
wieso zu lachen
und das ist genau die sind weiter diese
waren sarkastisch
[Musik]